[Musique]
j'ai beaucoup travaillé sur les ciments
dans une autre vie j'ai même été au
cimentier avant de devenir professeur et
puis à certé ya très longtemps que j'ai
compris que le ciment à certains moments
il faut trouver à le remplacer par
d'autres ce qu'on appelle des ajouts
cimentaire
[Musique]
ça c'est du ver mix donc ça c'est du
vert bois y est finement canton le
raffinement c'est le sait la couleur
naturelle de la silice qui prend le
dessus et donc c'est tout blanc
[Musique]
le secret la de la haute résistance et
de la haute performance c'est comment
est-ce que les particules soit vraiment
très très proche pour qu' il n'y ait pas
de porosité la plus grosse dimension on
va jouer avec le dosage des granulats du
sable etc mais il faut se rendre à
l'évidence que tout cet agencement que
l'on voit à l'échelle macro ont réalité
commence à l'échelle micro mêmes
nanométrique c'est à ce niveau là de
déchets qu'il faut travailler pour
améliorer bonifier les btan de qualité
les btan de demain etc
ce qu'on vient par nous dans notre
projet c'est qu'on va remplacer 10% de
la vie ciment par la côte de barr